[Music]
you can watch the clock all you want but
it won't go any faster you're Barry
Allen right Henry Allen's kid I'm axel
Walker you and your dad kidnapped my dad
was yeah right
pudding lunch lady gave me extra I think
she has a crush on me huh hey we're done
the block is you carved up some
professor he give you a bad grade or
something I didn't kill anybody
after everyone's innocent in here
especially that guy a big sir he's
really innocent
it says grosser than usual was putting
go bad back so what do you want from me
could be murder buds you know we could
see her trade secrets I'd love to hear
how you carved up that college quack I
don't need any France on here okay
man I do not feel good
get him up you got mud on my probably
once I'm sorry I didn't mean to Sarge
right
[Music]
first week and iron Heights is often the
hardest in styling
we've already seen what happens when a
few inmates try to revoke acclimating to
your new life will take time always does
in the meantime do your best to stay
clean in here
Oh mr. Alan your 130s waiting for you
[Music]
what I really need guys is a new
superhero named Ramon you vetted all
this time you can't come up with
anything patience okay I'm getting to
you I've just been a little preoccupied
what with Barry being in prison and all
up so 411 the elongated Knight Rises
this is now that Barry is spending his
time in jail and iron Heights part of
the focus of being the hero for central
city falls on your friendly neighborhood
superhero did me is indestructible this
all sort of comes to a head when Axl
Walker is broken on a prison by none
other than his mother Frank come on Axl
well Frank diehard fans remember played
by Corinth or from the 90s television
show flash behind every great trick
isn't even better drink
[Laughter]
hey everybody we got new flash tonight a
big deep cut from the classic flash TV
series in some crazy iris West
speedster stuff happening later this
season so let's break it down I'll start
with this episode then at the end of the
video I'll talk about iris West
speedster goings-on because there might
be some shenanigans going on like she
might not actually become a speedster
there might be some big twist behind it
obviously the tip off of the episode the
elongated Knight Rises is the elongated
Knight maybe getting his comic book name
his comic book costume with a big Dark
Knight Easter Egg but the really cool
thing here is that it brought prank back
from the classic 90s TV series if you
remember she was sort of the assistant
like Mark Hamill talks about it in a
really funny way at the time she was
just this normal person that Stockholm
Syndrome started to become the Harley
Quinn to mark Hamill's trickster this
was way before he ever became the Joker
so his trickster on the 90s flash TV
series was sort of a proto version of
what his animated series Joker became he
went on to become the Joker after the
flash TV series was cancelled like they
were actually getting ready for a big
rogue team-up but the TV series got
canceled so he went on to other jobs you
know I've been reading lately how old
guano man is wound tight enough to snap
you could see a little bit of the Joker
behind that classic performance but they
are two distinct characters but in the
way that dr. Harleen Quinzel Stockholm
Syndrome joined the Joker became Harley
Quinn they actually did it a couple
years earlier than that with prank in
the trickster so it becomes this really
meta thing and it obviously pranks
character is very different from what
Arleen Sorkin did with the Harley Quinn
character so obviously they're all very
different people but you can kind of see
the moves that they were making at the
time because Harley Quinn was actually a
character that debuted on the TV series
before she debuted in the comics but
Mark Hamill said way way back the whole
idea was is that eventually they got
together she had a child that child
became the axle Walker trickster
no one gets you but me
I've spent my entire life looking for
bigger and bigger kicks aren't you go
ahead to see your little sidekick Frank
the real reason I tracked you down and
groomed you to be the best you could
possibly be Axl I have your father
so when Jeff Jones was writing the comic
book arc that the flash TV show is doing
right now the thinker art axle was not
related to the Jesse James trickster he
just stole all of his stuff and tried to
take his name and eventually they fought
each other Jesse James took his name
back then eventually he went away and
Axl became the main version of the
trickster
it for the most part within the Rogues
he's kind of a punching bag character
right now if you haven't been reading
the comics they're doing an iron Heights
run they brought god speed back the
stuff that's been happening to him is so
hardcore that I would probably get
demonetised if I tried to explain it
let's just say if you're not like a
really big dude and you're a rogue and
you get thrown in prison it's not gonna
be very easy for you which is you know
brings us to the flash TV show Barry in
prison we also found out who Goldberg's
character is playing so it'll be
interesting to see because it looks like
he's getting stabbed during the trailer
so it just looks like he goes through
the typical prison experience it just
has to figure out how to deal with it
without using his powers like they say
no prison can hold you there's even
scenes with Ralph's didney visiting him
in prison maybe Cisco ports him in or he
goes in the legit way to visit him
because it looks like he's wearing his
elongated man costume so it's not like
he would walk through the front door
with that he has to engineer a scenario
where the thinker is caught red-handed
with his wife so that they could just
walk around in broad daylight like they
used to otherwise they'd be on the run
for the rest of his life but it does
sound like he's gonna be in prison for
the next couple of episodes so they'll
be doing their version of Shawshank
it'll be interesting to see what the
inside of iron Heights looks like
because you look in the background of
some of these shots it is just nuts
there's just like a riot every five
minutes but we did find out you know
speaking of Prison Break make all the
Prison Break jokes that you want we did
learn that they're doing the big robes
team-up the blacksmith engineers during
the Jeff Jones thinker arc it actually
starts with a big rogue team-up that
they opted not to do when they first
introduced the blacksmith character on
the TV show we don't know how close
they're sticking to the comic book
storyline but we do know they're doing a
version of the network which is really
just like a black market network that
blacksmith sets up and the other rogues
are her underlings so they're bringing
weather wizard back pretty much all the
big rogues that aren't tied up on other
TV shows or haven't gone away like
captain cold
seems like he's off-limits for now like
Wentworth Miller seemed like
he was riding off into the sunset so who
knows when he comes back heat wave is on
legend so I'm guessing he's not gonna
pop up and speaking of legends even
though it's not coming back to the
second week in February for that
two-part Constantine episode Kenyan
Lonsdale was thanking everybody on
Twitter like you know if you really care
about Wally West's journey he sounds
like he and the producers agreed that
Wally West's character just wasn't
getting the time that he needed for a
genuine art in with firestorm leaving
the spot opened up so the like okay that
just seems like a no-brainer we'll send
him to legends they didn't say anything
about what he would be doing aside from
just being the Wally West version of the
flash so they've been a lot of theories
about how they're gonna incorporate his
powers with the rest of the team because
like we said before he's the new most
powerful member of the team and I don't
think that he's going to be around for
the legends finale I think he comes back
to the flash for the flash finale before
that happens in schedule update when
legends comes back in the middle of
February episode 10 & 11 will be those
two Constantine episodes Wally doesn't
appear till maybe like the very end of
episode 12 but really episode 13 they
said is the first Wally episode then he
does his run then comes back to the
flash so make as many speedster puns as
you want the iris west speedster twist
could just be her dressed in a costume
but it looks like a slightly different
version of the Jessie quick costume
which itself was a version of the
trajectory costume so they could just be
repurposing a version of that she could
be from an alternate earth or because we
know Cecile is getting powers from her
pregnancy this could be the tip-off for
we're going to need more diapers so I'll
do a separate video about why iris West
might get powers later this season but
just remember that there are a number of
reasons why she might be dressed up in a
speedster costume but there is a new
round of that flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber share the video using those
YouTube tools on the watch page below my
episode video will post after it airs
tonight there is new Deadpool that I'll
try to post before flash starts tonight
and for those of you asking yes I will
do a Black Lightning episode 2 video
that'll post Wednesday morning so while
you wait for everything click here for
more new flash and click here for all
that new Black Panther footage thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight